des dogons va retrouver donc notre
correspondant kalidou aussi hier soir à
l'elysée ont été invités les présidents
des pays du g5 celle à l'exception dont
bien sûr du mali et du burkina faso
justement suspendu des instances de
l'union africaine à la suite des coups
d'état bonjour à vous kalidou le burkina
qui est donc en première ligne de la
violence djihadiste au sahel sur place
les sentiments sont partagés sur le
départ des soldats français le retrait
des troupes françaises qui vient tout
juste d'être annoncé qu'est-ce qu'il
suscite sur place il inquiète autant
qu'il qui le réjouit peut-être
écouté honnêtement sur place la grande
actualité c'est l'investiture du
président damiba qui a eu lieu hier
trois semaines après le coup d'état qui
a renversé l'ex-président kaboré
la la place du retrait de bach cad au
mali n'a pas fait la une des journaux
mais néanmoins quelques zones en ligne
et quelques quotidiens en ont parlé je
prends l'exemple du journal
l'observateur paalga qui dans son
éditorial à poser la question de savoir
si le nouveau pouvoir en place à
ouagadougou va poursuivre dans la
dynamique du partenariat avec l'hexagone
où une secousse il tombera alors patron
de go ita de rompre avec la douce et
généreuse france dans le journal en
ligne wasquehal fait rare on se demande
ce sera un sommet en plus ou un sommet
plus un jeu de mots la question se pose
maintenant plus que jamais non seulement
la multitude de ces rencontres ont été
groupe de grosse montagne qui accouche
invariablement de petites souris et
comme on peut le voir ils n'attendent
pas grand-chose de ce sommet
du côté burkinabè depuis la prise de
pouvoir du lieutenant-colonel damiba qui
désormais président il n'y a pas eu de
déclaration officielle sur une volonté
de continuer de collaborer avec la
france mais on peut être qu'il ya des
signaux qui pourrait laisser penser à ce
scénario d'abord à l'occasion de la
cérémonie d'investiture de sa prestation
de serment hier matin dans son discours
le président damiba a déclaré en ces
moments difficiles notre pays n'a pas
été abandonné par ses partenaires c'est
l'occasion pour moi de remercier la
communauté internationale tous les
efforts consentis pour accompagner le
burkina faso il a également ajouté le
burkina faso réitère de sa disponibilité
à travailler en toute souveraineté avec
tous les partenaires dans le respect
mutuel alors on a bon on sait qu'il ya
trois jours aussi le chef d'état major
français le général thierry burkhard a
eu un entretien téléphonique avec son
homologue burkinabè le colonel major
david cabré pour échanger sur la
coopération entre les deux pays dans
laquelle le chef d'état major français a
réaffirmé de la vente et de la france
d'aider de burkina faso à faire face à
la menace terroriste pour la paix et la
stabilité dans la région dans la raison
pardon côté opérations sur terrain le 10
février dernier en accord et en
coordination avec les forces d'un les
burkinabè barkan avait mené une
opération qui avait visé une unité du
génie ou de soutien liscano mutuellement
hafid al qaïda dans laquelle 40
terroristes ont été neutralisés sont en
bilan français et rappelons que selon
l'état major français c'est ce groupe
djihadiste qui serait responsable des
deux attaques le 8 février au bénin à la
frontière du burkina faso qui avait
causé la mort d'une dizaine de gardes
forestiers de llorente africain parc
dont un français un ancien militaire et
conseiller auprès des béninois donc
voilà pas d'annoncé officielle du côté
burkinabè mais je dirais que c'est steam
sont plutôt favorables pour continuer
coopération militaire avec la france au
moment où je vous parle on en saura plus
peut-être après le sommet